so as we continue our discussion on all
new all different marvel we pick up now
with jason ahrens the mighty thor now
one of the funny things about this is
the mighty thor has really split the
thor community there are some fans that
really want odin's son to come back and
odin son will come back that's one of
the things that happens at this and at
the end of the story and that's why i
titled it the return of odin's son
because this will actually feature the
first appearance of odin son since the
events of secret wars came to an end and
all knew all different marvels started
we'll talk about we'll talk more about
that once we get to the end of this
video but there are other people who
welcome jane foster i personally love
jane foster thor i think she's a
well-written thor i think she's one hell
of a character and i think it was a
great decision by jason aaron to make
her thor because it takes jane foster
out of the role of being just kind of a
person that's just a supporting
character in thor's life and gives her a
significant role within the realm of
marvel comics what we're also going to
talk about here in this video is that
jason aaron effectively put her on a
ticking clock but what i want to do here
is i want to backtrack a little bit
because with all new all different
marvel not everything was rebooted there
were some new stories that showed up
like ultimates you know there's things
like champions that have their roots in
the current run of avengers uncanny
avengers and new avengers but for the
mighty thor there's really no reboot to
be had here there's no refreshing
instead jason aaron largely continues on
from before secret wars he does give us
a little bit of a refresher in terms of
jane foster but he doesn't really offer
much in the way of malikith the accursed
of the serpent it's really just kind of
confusing if you're picking this up for
the very first time so for those of you
guys who have found yourself kind of a
you know feeling like a lost ball in
high weeds when it came to the start of
the mighty thor i'm hoping these next
few minutes will clear things up for you
so the first thing i want to talk about
here is the serpent his cold war son now
he will play a minor role in this he
won't really be like a major focal point
but he still does have a role to play
with regards to the marvel landscape
specifically the realm of asgard cole
borson was one of the brothers of odin
originally in marvel comics it was
simply odin veli and v and that was it
and what we knew was that odin had
basically secured the odin force created
the odin force by absorbing the life
energies of his brothers and merging
them into himself now that's the
original continuity that's the way it
had always been marvel came along and
they wrote a story called fear itself
and fear itself centered on the on the
introduction of cold bore sun and the
idea that odin actually had a third
brother but that that cold bore son had
basically gone crazy with his own power
and ruled his own realm using fear now
where odin did defeat borson or did
defeat cole what ended up happening is
that odin couldn't actually kill his
brother and so instead he imprisoned him
inside the oceans of earth and had thor
basically keep an eye and watched
midgard in order to make sure that coal
would never leave that's one of the
reasons why earth was so closely tied to
asgard some of it had to do with the
fact that thor was part of the protector
of earth but the largest part of it was
that odin wanted to keep an eye on earth
to make sure that cole could not
actually escape and that if he did then
odin would be there to stop him the
issue was that during the events of fear
itself coldbore's son did escape by
virtue of his daughter's sin now again
during the events of fear itself all
this stuff was explained to us but
because of the fact that cold bore son
had his own hammer because of the fact
that he wanted to take over earth and
then eventually take over asgard take
over as ruler kicking odin out of his
current place the idea here was that he
was eventually defeated what what also
happened though was that he was
basically stationed on asgard not so
much as a hero or an ally so much as a
guy who was just there so that odin
could keep an eye on him now with
regards to malakith the accursed
malachithia curse was an extremely
obscure character in fact you'd only
ever really know about him if you'd done
any measure of reading or read any of
the stories surrounding the cast of
ancient winners but malekith rose to
prominence of course as we know with
thor the dark world of course that story
dealt with malikith leading the dark
elves in a campaign across the world
trying to merge the realms into one
another and so on and so forth the mcu
version is different from the version
that we have in the comics but the fact
remains that because malikithi occurs
was the main villain in thor the dark
world he gained popularity gain traction
and marvel comics from people who wanted
to know who he was and so what jason
aaron did is he basically rolled
malikithya curse over from being an
obscure character to being the main
villain of the jane foster thor line of
stories now the way he did this is he
actually had malachithia curse become
part and parcel or begin to engage in
shady practices with roxanne oil now
roxanne oil has also been mentioned a
ton of times in the marvel cinematic
universe but it's not nearly as
prominent in the movie universe as it is
in the comics the roxon oil is kind of
like the lead cd corporation it's the
lead bad corporation if it will give
them money if they can make money off of
it they will do it it doesn't matter
what it is they'll assassinate people
they will imprison people illegally
they'll kill people i mean they'll do
all kinds of different things they'll
engage in illegal acts of all sorts so
long as it turns a profit and it gets
them a foothold with regards to having
an edge over the competition now the
competition of course is alkamax
different things like that even stark
and parker industries are considered to
be competitors to roxanne oil they're
not nearly as unsavory as roxanne but
the idea is that roxanne will do what it
takes in order to turn a profit the the
other half of this coin was that
malikithi occurs within this line of
comics by jason aaron wanted to take
over the nine realms and eventually set
his sights on asgard and be the
undisputed ruler of all existence for
the most part but he couldn't do this on
his own he needed a multitude of forces
in order to make this happen and so what
he intended to do was launch a campaign
to first secure the loyalty of the frost
giants the problem with this was that
the existing ruler of the frost giants
the existing leader would not ally
himself with malachithia curse but
during the early days of asgard when
odin had defeated the frost giants and
adopted loki as a son during the battle
lofi was killed but because laffy was
kind of this honored dead of the frost
giants because of the fact that if he
ever were to come back all the frost
giants would swear absolute loyalty to
him including the existing king who
would step aside and allow laffy to take
the place as king malachithia curse came
to realize that if he were to resurrect
laffy he would likely be able to sway
laffy to his side and in turn get the
loyalty of all the frost giants and so
what laffy did and this actually
coincided with the first story arc of
jane foster thor what happened is
malikith traveled to earth he found that
roxanne oil had secured the skull of
laffy and he invaded roxanne oil but
roxanne saw this as an opportunity to
expand their own profits because of the
fact that malikith wanted to invade the
realms those realms have materials that
could not be found on earth and so
roxanne rationalized that if they could
secure those materials they could in
turn sell them on earth to anyone who
would be willing to buy them and fetch a
huge amount of money and so what roxanne
oil did is they said they would give
malakith the accursed the skull of lofi
but only under the condition the
malachithia curse allowed them to
basically take the minerals from the the
realms that he conquers and sell them on
earth hence an alliance was formed
between malakith and roxanne oil now
again this ties into the introduction of
jane foster thor and the way this worked
was during the original sins story arc
when thor odin's son lost his ability to
use his hammer when nick fury said
whatever it was that he said we didn't
know exactly what was going to happen we
didn't know how things were going to
work it was assumed by us as the reader
that something would happen somewhere
along the line where thor got the
ability to wield his hammer again but
that didn't happen instead jason aaron
had someone else pick up his hammer
which was later on revealed to be jane
foster who was dying of cancer now
because of the fact that odin's son did
not know that jane foster was thor when
she was diagnosed with cancer he
initially offered her the opportunity to
attend asgard's you know magic slash
medical facilities and purge the cancer
from her body but jane foster chose not
to and so instead thor basically granted
her the opportunity to uh to be part of
the council of realms which is to say
the senate that exists where each of the
realms sends a representative in order
to work out the various problems or
disagreements that the realms may have
with one another the problem was that
once jane foster became thor while she
was undergoing chemotherapy every time
she became thor it would purge the
chemotherapy from her body it would
effectively send her back to zero in
terms of her cancer treatment but the
cancer itself was continually
progressing and so what jason aaron did
is he basically said yes jane foster is
currently thor but she's on a ticking
clock it's only a matter of time before
she succumbs to the cancer that's
killing her because she keeps wiping out
the chemotherapy from her body and so
again this is basically why i call this
the return of odin's son because this
appears to be jason aaron setting the
stage for the return of thor now we know
that thor will have his own story uh for
the unworthy but i wouldn't be surprised
if somewhere along the line odin's son
went back to the position of being thor
as we knew him before jane foster took
over that position but with that being
said with all that stuff being added and
hopefully that wasn't too chaotic for
you guys hopefully you understand it but
what we do now is we actually jump
forward into the story arc of the return
of odin's son of the first story arc
from the mighty thor as part of all new
all different marvel
now this story arc initially picks up
with jason aaron kind of giving us a
refresher on jane foster more or less
what i had said about the idea that
every time she changes into thor that it
wipes away the chemotherapy from her
body it tells us of course that jane
foster is suffering from cancer but more
so than that we see him immediately
initiating this idea of the war of the
realms when the satellite or when a
satellite of roxanne oil is suddenly set
upon by what appears to be lidel's from
one of the nine realms uh who have all
been killed and are simply just crashing
back to earth the issue with this is
that because these people from the
different realms of of you know one of
the nine realms rather are so durable
because they're all roughly equivalent
to thor maybe a little bit weaker in
terms of durability and strength they
immediately tear through the hole of
this ship and i guess of the satellite
and the result is that it sends a
satellite crashing down to earth now
with jane foster watching tv and seeing
these things happening she immediately
calls mjolnir to her and she becomes
thor and she takes off alongside the
rest of the avengers in order to keep
people as safe as they can from this
satellite that's crashing into the
ground now for the most part they are
successful in doing this but once jane
foster and vision and a handful of
others travel into space to see what's
going on they realize that there is
there are some of these elves that have
written on them so begins the war of the
nine realms and so what happens is she
travels back to uh back to the hospital
she secures volstag and the two of them
basically head off to asgard now when
they get there this is something i
wanted to touch on real quick and i
actually waited until this part of the
story to uh to get into this because i
didn't want to bombard you guys with too
much too fast in terms of backstory when
she gets to asgard there are signs all
over the place that say false thor and
this is one of the reasons why this is
so cool because when jason aaron created
uh jane foster thor i imagine that for
the most part he knew there was going to
be backlash from traditional thor fans
and he created the sort of meta
commentary in the story where even
people in asgard considered her to be a
false thor that she was a thief she had
stolen mjolnir it was never rightfully
hers this was also a major plot thread
for the events before secret wars in the
sense that odin himself had considered
her to be a false thor considered her to
be an impersonator and even tried to
have her imprisoned the result was that
freya had actually come to her aid had
taken up arms against odin and given uh
given jane foster the ability to escape
from from odin's judgment the downside
to this was that freya was thrown in
prison for her actions while she awaited
a trial by odin himself in order to
determine whether or not she was guilty
or she was innocent now from here we
actually end up jumping to the uh to the
council of realms themselves and we see
the light elves conversing with the dark
elves and you know people going back and
forth the the dwarves who of course are
well known for having fashioned the
hammer of thor in the first place and
the idea here is they're saying well
light elves are being killed everywhere
that uh that something needs to be done
to do this but the idea is that jane
foster counters this by saying that yes
these light elves are being killed but
it's not as though someone's killing
them for no reason there's a much bigger
thing going on here there's a much
bigger set of events taking place here
that someone is a hidden hand that
someone has started this conflict and so
again what we do is we pick up with jane
foster trying to find the source trying
to go to the realm of the light elves to
see what it is that's going on to get
more information than what the light
elves ambassadors are willing to reveal
now when she gets to the bifrost as we
know heimdall is the guardian of the
bifrost now one thing i want to touch on
here is that jason aaron does not really
change much of the asgardian mythos in
fact this i think was one of the
greatest aspects of his run on thor in
the sense that he kept a lot of it the
same for those of you guys who are
familiar with thor in the movies but
you're not wildly familiar with him in
the comics what you saw in the movies is
basically heimdall in the comics a
heimdall basically just guards the
bifrost he determines who can pass and
who cannot he serves at the behest of
the ruler of asgard whoever that ruler
happens to be whether it's odin or
someone else who takes his place now
heindall is an extremely capable warrior
in his own right he's one of those
strong silent types in the sense that he
rarely ever gets involved in conflicts
but when he does it is a sight to behold
because he absolutely lays waste to
whoever it is that he's going against
but because of the fact that odin
considers jane foster to be an
impersonator he's very much restricted
what it is that she can and cannot do
most notably she's not allowed to travel
to the realm of alpha she's not allowed
to go to the realm of the of the light
elves more so than that even if odin had
more or less kind of given her the
ability to do what she wanted to do this
is also still being hindered by cole
borsa now cole borson carries out odin's
law think of him as somewhat of a of a
sheriff so to speak in asgard in the
sense that because odin has basically
confined himself to the interior of
asgard because he never really leaves
he's more like an absentee king and cole
borson carries out his orders in his
stead and so on behalf of odin cole
borson has decreed that jane foster is
not allowed to go into the realm of
alfheim now from here we transition over
to uh to malakith himself in the yawning
void and the awning void is kind of this
place hidden from all reality it's one
of those locations that heimdall can't
see and so what happens is malachithia
curse is of course talking to roxanne
oil talking about how roxanne oil will
be able to make money off of the various
resources from the realms that the
malikith conquers but the other half of
this is that someone wants to join the
ranks of their dark alliance so to speak
someone wants to become part of their
part of their group now the initial idea
is this may be uh someone that we
haven't seen yet maybe it's cold or son
himself operating from the shadows but
what we learned is that it's actually
loki who wants to join part of their
alliance and this is a big deal because
again this sees the first appearance of
loki following the events of secret wars
but something else that i also want you
guys to take note of here is that over
the course of the story we're actually
going to see jason aaron give us
different versions of loki it's going to
be a singular battle but it'll be all
the versions of loki that we've ever
seen over the course of his history
which is really really going to be a
cool moment but the idea here is that in
order for loki to become part of the
frost giants because of the fact that
laffy has since been resurrected and
because laffy is leading the frost giant
in order for loki to become part of this
dark alliance he has to pass a series of
tests that are going to be administered
by laffy now this is a really cool
discussion here because this is the
first time that loki has ever
encountered laffy in his current form
that is to say right now in this moment
as his father there have been times
where loki traveled into the past where
loki has met lafaye before but it's
never been anything like this this is
about as close as the two of them get as
a kind of bonding moment of sorts but
what we're told by jason aaron and what
he shows us is that lofi has no loss of
love for loki he considers loki to be a
shameful indication of his offspring he
he considers loki to be something less
than a strong son you know kind of a i
guess a disappointment so to speak now
transitioning back to asgard
transitioning back to uh to thor what
she says is that she is going to go to
the realm of alzheimer's she's not going
to be held back and that morson is the
least likely person to ever get in her
way still because of the fact that she
could easily take him on with the power
of mjolnir now something to point out
here is that if it was just jane foster
herself and all she had was like the axe
yarn bjorn or something like that she'd
be stomped easily just because of the
fact that that cold bore son is so
powerful but mjolnir with the magic that
it holds with the powers that it
possesses it gives her the edge over
over cold war son simply just by virtue
of what it's capable of now when she
goes through and she's able to take out
the forces of cold borson his experience
in battle is the one thing that causes
him to gain the upper hand and that was
the reason why i ran over that little
segment a second ago because cold bore
son does get the upper hand on her but
this is experience this is not strength
and it's not power this is simply
because of the fact that cole borson has
been a ruler much longer than jane
foster has cole borson has been a
fighter much longer than jane foster has
and so cole warson knows how to work
around the powers of thor and he knows
how to work around the powers of the
asgardians now something else is really
interesting here is that while this
conflict is taking place this is why i
love jason aaron's writing so much
heindall doesn't lift a finger he
doesn't do anything initially instead he
just guards the bridge because that's
his job and that's what he does but this
is why i say that he is a force to be
reckoned with when he gets into the
combat because once cold bore son says
or once he once he reveals that he
believes jane foster to be a a traitor
once he says that she is not the
rightful owner of mjolnir that hammer
belongs to thor he intends to actually
cut off her hands because she considers
her to be a thief but right at the
moment of the striking blow heimdall
puts his sword in the way and blocks the
attack now cole borson talks a tough
game here all right he's basically more
or less like you know how why would you
do this you know you cannot get in my
way out operating on the orders of of
odin but he doesn't actually make a move
to attack heimdall and the reason why is
because you know in part of my language
here heimdall would stomp his [ __ ] like
that's just the way it is he would
absolutely crush cold war son it would
be
i kind of wish jason aaron had shown us
that it would have been awesome but the
fact remains here that because heimdall
works indirectly because he kind of does
his own thing he uses this as an excuse
to basically send jane foster off to
alfheim and then he turns around and
surrenders himself to uh to cole borson
now this is really more of an honorable
act by heimdall to simply allow himself
to be turned over because for him it's
the law above all else he will happily
act against the will of odin but he will
also turn himself over to the
consequences of those acts time doll
does not go rogue heimdall does not defy
and then avoid the consequences and
that's one of the cool things about his
character he's kind of you know a
representation of the last vestiges of
honorable men so to speak and so once
jane foster is sent off to uh sent off
to alfheim she eventually does what she
can to uh to find out everything that's
going on but we also learn that alpheim
is in the middle of a massive invasion
by the combined forces of roxanne oil
and the dark elves of malakith now in
addition to this once thor arrives she
is able to hold her own against these
forces cast them off as best she can but
then we also learn the plot thickens and
not only is malakith occurs in an
alliance with roxanne oil the frost
giants and a handful of others he's also
in an alliance with the enchantress now
the enchantress seems to have her own
motivations here for those of you guys
who don't know the enchantress is a
wildly powerful witch in the realm of
asgard she's extremely capable because
what we're talking about when we talk
about asgardians we're talking about the
level of gods now in my research i don't
know exactly where she stands in
relation to like doctor strange i know
that before doctor strange lost his
powers lost his connection to the
vashanti and got them back but was less
powerful than he was before which is
where people get the reference
pre-retcon and post-retcon doctor
strange i know that that pre-recon
doctor strange was extremely powerful he
was multiversal powerful i mean he could
do whatever he wanted to because he had
the power to do it he would probably be
able to go toe-to-toe if not overcome
enchantress doctor strange right now in
marvel comics is kind of a tough
comparison it's kind of a tough uh a
tough analysis here enchantress can hold
her own in a multitude of different ways
she can take on gods she can challenge
gods but so can doctor strange so again
it's kind of a tough comparison in fact
i'll leave that to you guys down in the
comments section who do you think is
more powerful the enchantress and asgard
or dr strange because i'm actually kind
of curious to see what answers you guys
come up with but the motivation behind
enchantress being involved in the uh and
the alliance of malakith is to basically
say that she wants thor as a husband she
wants to have thor all to herself and
it's always really been this way you
know enchantress has always been
obsessed with thor this is one of the
reasons why when the unknown woman first
picked up thor's hammer before we
realized it was jane foster the rumors
were circling around everywhere that we
went to but one of the one of the ideas
is that people thought it was
enchantress they thought that she became
for whatever reason she was found worthy
of wieldy mjolnir and became the next
thor but the fact remains here that we
switch back over to loki and loki was
basically given a test by his father
laffy to go against four of uh of
laffy's absolute best and strongest
warriors but loki was able to defeat
them now this is where jason aaron
really highlights the power of loki loki
is very strong in comparison to your
normal earthlings loki for example could
easily take on captain america or
somebody like that you know he could
easily go toe-to-toe with him loki's
actually gone totally tough with
villains like apocalypse and even the
incredible hulk despite what you guys
saw in the avengers movie loki has gone
toe-to-toe with the incredible hulk he'd
be outclassed extremely fast because the
incredible hulk's anger would reach a
level where he would just be so strong
that loki wouldn't stand a chance but
he's still very capable but loki and of
himself is not a warrior loki is a
trickster and so he uses his
intelligence in order to overcome
situations and that's what he did here
he basically began manipulating the
minds of these warriors and and what he
did is he basically had one of the
warriors kill the other three and then
drove this warrior to insanity and so
again this is just kind of loki having
people fight his battles for him
tricking them but he also has a
conversation with his father lofi and
what he says is that this is all just
one big waste of time that if loki was
not capable if loki was not strong
enough to survive in the world of asgard
then he wouldn't have made it this long
he wouldn't have lasted as long in
different conflicts as he has been he
would have been killed off very fast and
so either either laffy can get his act
together and tell him what's going on or
loki will simply just abandon laffy or
attack his father and drive him insane
and so this seems to be what laffy was
waiting for he was waiting for loki to
be the honorable son that he knew but
again what we're actually going to find
here or at least what we find next is
that laffy still hates his son he still
hates loki he considers loki to be a
shameful thing you know he considers
loki to be something less honorable than
what a frost giant should be and so
again this is basically the conversation
that he has with malikith when they're
on alphon and what what laffy says is
his intention is to kill both loki and
the the light elves or at least to
enslave the light elves and then turn
around and rule earth or rule asgard
alongside malikith again the motivations
of laffy were a little uh a little
skeptical here but the fact remains that
once we're back on alfheim once we're
dealing with thor who's trying to secure
the queen of queen of the white elves
she's eventually met with the arrival of
loki himself now again thor i guess jane
foster thor has had a couple run-ins
with loki but never anything real never
anything tangible like what odin's son
has and so odin's son's world verse and
odin's son would know right off the bat
incapacitate loki and call it a day
because no one knows what loki's going
to do he's crazy in the things that he
does but i would love for you guys to
remember this because what we're going
to learn i think probably in the next
story arc or so is there's a lot more to
loki's actions than what's going on here
loki is what you see is not necessarily
what's happening i will say that like
what you see is not necessarily what's
going on i know it's mysterious i know
it's kind of
you know cloak and dagger but you know
it's it just goes towards the writing of
jason aaron but the fact remains here
that loki basically i guess what jason
aaron does is he actually addresses us
as the reader and this is what's really
cool when jane foster thor first popped
up like i said earlier there were a lot
of people who didn't like the idea of a
new thor who wanted to see the same old
odin son but what jason aaron says by
way of loki having a conversation with
uh with with jane foster thorpe is he
says myself and odin's son have done
that dance time and time again you know
how often can we really see this same
situation going around in circles and
this is really just jason aaron saying
look you guys have had thor for almost
40 years you know how of how much can
you guys really see the same stories
over and over and over and over again
this is all new all different marvel
things need to be new and they need to
be different granted it's not as new or
as different as we wanted it to be but
this is jason aaron telling us you're
getting something new and you're getting
something different you wanted new and
you wanted different why are you
complaining and so this is kind of
interesting to me because it addresses
the reader it addresses naysayers but in
response to jason aaron i would say it's
not really a complaint about something
new so much as it is there's history
there there's legacy there people like
odin son because they they've been with
him for so long but people like jane
foster because she's new it's really a
mixed bag when it comes to comic book
readers there's no real right and wrong
here people who like thor like him
because he's had great stories
godbutcher was an incredible story
people like jane foster because she had
great stories and she's coming into her
own as a superhero people are literally
following her as she's learning what it
means to be for but the fact remains
here that you know with regards to this
situation i'm actually kind of curious
too post now i know this is gonna be a
really controversial question post down
and uh tell me who you like more do you
like odin's son or do you like jane
foster and i know this is going to
create some argument in the comments
section please try to keep it civil guys
please do not insult each other i know
it's a lot to ask but the fact remains
that that you know jane foster has had
enough run-ins with loki in the past to
know that he does need to be
incapacitated so she immediately uses
her hammer and knocks his head off and
from here loki begins conjuring all
these different versions of himself over
the years there's a incredible hulk
version of loki there's the original
loki when he first showed up in the thor
comics there's the modern loki there's
the kid loki there's the woman loki
there's all these different versions
there's the loki from secret wars when
he was a homeless man there's all these
different versions of him which is
really really cool you know in terms of
what jason aaron is giving us but what
we also find out is that loki's these
different loki's begin conversing with
themselves and loki basically has all
these different personalities each one
is its own self and so these are almost
like they're operating independently of
the whole but they're still part of loki
i don't know if that makes any sense at
all but in the end the fact remains that
jane foster realizes that in order for
her to continue with her plan loki at
the very least has to be defeated or he
has to be held at bay he has to be kind
of pushed away from being a credible
threat and so when she asked the
question why are you here you know
what's going on with malachithia curse
why are you allied with him why are they
invading alpheim loki says basically i
was a distraction and the distraction
was i'm waiting for them and so what
happens is when she looks up she
realizes that there are the forces of
loki who are arriving with nuclear bombs
under the control of roxanne oil and so
the idea seems to be that they are going
to start dropping these bombs everywhere
and they're going to wipe out the
entirety of roxanne oil but instead what
happens is uh jane foster uses her
hammer she uses her power of lightning
and she takes out all these bombs now
this is one of the reasons that i like
so much about this is because again
we're following jane foster on her
journey to learn about what it means to
be thor and this is one of the big
things one of the things that she has to
recognize is that as a superhero there
comes a time when you may have to
sacrifice your life to do the right
thing she doesn't actually die here but
is her accepting the fact that she is
the goddess of thunder that she cannot
be limited by what she thinks she can
and cannot do she simply just has to do
what needs to be done and so she is
successful in doing this she is
successful in taking out these various
forces the problem is that it pushes her
to a weakened state and she loses her
connection to the hammer and actually
transitions back to her normal human
form now what we do here is we actually
end up jumping back to the trial of
freya by her husband odin and what
happens is odin again touches back on
what we had talked about earlier where
freya had been the person that it made
it possible for thor to escape odin's
judgment she had made it possible for
thor to get away and you know return
back to the planet earth but what we
also learn here is that in the
background of these events the goal of
uh the goal of malikith was to actually
wed the uh where the light elf queen
thereby taking over her realm and taking
over all the resources of the light
elves now how this ties into the bigger
picture will be again covered later on
and what we'll actually learn is he's
simply just going to keep her as a
prisoner and do the exact same thing
across the other realms basically take
over as absolute ruler and what this
does is it basically makes it official
and what i mean by that is in the realm
of asgard or i guess in the nine realms
you know rulership is determined by
different ways if you have like a
barbarian clan like the the frost giants
the current ruler is whoever it is that
can take over as ruler whoever the
strongest of the frost giants is is the
one that becomes the king and it's a
constant challenge there will constantly
be other frost giants who will rise up
and try to take their place and if you
cannot defeat them they will take your
place and they'll be viewed as the king
with the light elves it's really more of
a monarchy kind of thing it's really
more of a high class you know more
organized more structured society and
because of the fact that it deals so
much with heritage and royalty marriage
is how you become the ruler of that
realm not really through combat and so
if malachithia curse had killed the
queen of the uh of the light elves then
the other forces would have just fought
to the death but if he marries her it
makes him king and because of that they
now have to follow his orders by loyalty
to the crown it's really just more
following custom and using subservience
as a way to take over a realm as opposed
to just killing everything that exists
and so again jumping back to freyja this
is one of the cool things here is
because of the fact that odin had kept
himself so confined inside of asgard
because of the fact that he wanted
virtually nothing to do with what was
going on he failed to take notice of a
of a very significant set of events that
were taking place in asgard and what i
mean here is that much like us as the
reader base jason aaron took the
derisive aspect of jane foster becoming
thor and threw it into asgard like some
of you prefer odin's son where some of
you prefer jane foster in the realm of
asgard there are some who view thor who
view jane foster as being a thief who
view her as a false thor but there are
others who say the hammer chose her and
so she is the thor and what this did is
it created a rift it basically set
asgard on a position of civil war and so
what happened here is basically odin
while he was inside of his realm failed
to take notice of the fact that forces
are moving against him while his own
forces are trying to protect him and
it's basically created a state of civil
war within asgard itself and so what
happens here is outside of this of the
castle i guess outside of the main
chamber of odin we see that the forces
of the warriors three are leading the
other i guess i guess leading other
groups of asgardians against the forces
of col borson and his soldiers and so
again odin refuses to take note of this
owen refuses to accept that this is
what's happening in addition to this
while he's in the middle of getting
ready to pronounce guilt over freyja
jane foster arrives and jane foster and
odin engage in this massive battle
between the two of them now this is
where i say the return of odin's son
begins to come into play while odin is a
very formidable threat and while he
could easily get the upper hand on jane
foster one of the cool things is that
she's not bound by loyalty to odor and
this is one of the reasons why a
conflict between thor and odin would be
pretty one-sided on odin's behalf
because odinson would have a very hard
time attacking his father he'd have a
very hard time killing his father if it
came down to it but jane foster does not
hold that loyalty and so what happens
here is that with everything that's
taking place and everything that's going
on we also learn that there is a whole
lot more with loki we learned that loki
becoming part of the council with
regards to the and actually i'm actually
kind of jumping ahead a bit here so i
apologize but we learned that loki
becoming part of the dark council
alongside malikith was done at the
orders of freyja in order to spy on
malikith and find out what he was doing
but what happens is that in the midst of
all this loki actually turns around and
stabs freya essentially kills her and
this is a major focal point now with
regards to the return of odin's son this
is initially a split-second thing and so
if you weren't looking for it you
wouldn't expect it but in the middle of
the conflict between between thor and
between odin odin suddenly stops and
turns around and says what did i just
sense and so for me when i first saw
this i was like oh my god odin's son is
coming back
i was like thorough and son is coming
back and i was i was so excited and it
really kind of blew me away but at the
end of all this when everything seems to
die down when everything seems to come
to an end we ultimately find that that
loki basically stabbed freya with a
poison blade and it effectively kills
her in addition to this we also find
that cole borson because he has loyalty
to the crown because he has loyalty to
odin and to freya immediately turns his
axe on loki but we also learned that
cold war son in and of himself also has
a role to play here in the sense that
after the death of freya that odin had
basically retreated into his own realm
retreated into into the i guess i guess
place freya in what was considered to be
the odin sleep but also went back into
his own uh into his own arcanum you know
i guess for lack of a better word that
uh in his stead while he was absent that
cold bore son took up the mantle of
regent of asgard now a region basically
means that you're operating as ruler
instead you know in the place of the
king but it's only designed to be
temporary we also learned that again
loki is still allied with with the frost
giants at least they believe he's still
allied with him but we also end up
transitioning to some other side of the
universe or somewhere else in a distant
location and this is when we see the
return of odinson i know a lot of you
guys have probably been wondering right
now where's odin's son when do we get
his return it's only small but this is
jason aaron telling us he's coming back
this is the first appearance of odin's
son since the events of secret wars the
first time we've ever seen him and so
this is jason aaron saying i didn't wipe
him out of existence i didn't wretch him
out of existence he's not gone forever
he's here and he is going to be coming
back
members of the rob core i goofed
i screwed up a lot of you guys who are
kind of new here and who were going
through a lot of the videos that i had
for all new older marvel are probably
asking yourself rob didn't you already
do like the lords of midgard uh the
video was titled lords of midgard i
actually screwed up that was thunder in
her veins i don't know why i titled it
volume two lords of midgard it may have
been that i was going through and i was
trying to figure out what i was gonna do
next and ended up jumping into that one
but yeah i screwed up
i made a mistake but in the event this
is actually the lords of midgard now
this is really just kind of one of these
stories that expands a little bit on
jane foster but it doesn't go into like
the whole mythology of like the 10
realms or i guess yeah really the 10
realms now if we count heaven it doesn't
go into like the whole mythology of the
10 realms it kind of takes it aside for
a second and it actually focuses on a
guy named dario agger now this is what
jason aaron does when jason aaron goes
through and writes stories whenever he
crafts stories which he did it a lot
when he wrote the incredible hulk and it
was really really good the way it was
done but one of the things he does is he
sits down and he says okay let's have
this story here we have this character
off doing this thing and then in the
middle of that we're gonna focus on
something else over here it seems like
it's out in the middle of nowhere it
seems like it just comes from nowhere
but there's a basis behind it all this
story does that as well as the untold
origin of mjolnir which we did cover
that does that it's really just kind of
expanding the mythology and a lot of
writers do that jeff johns did it with
green lantern hickman did it with
fantastic four and avengers a lot of
it's just kind of expanding on existing
mythos because as the story opens up it
really focuses a lot on jane foster just
kind of reminding us of where she's at
now this also coincides with the idea of
loki running for president which again
we cover that you know vote loki thing
during the presidential election it was
a fun little one-off you know with loki
it wasn't a great big huge thing but
this idea of bolstering the thor
landscape initially comes to us by way
of something called the universal bank
now the universal bank has never been
seen before never been mentioned before
but it's really just one of these
instances where a marvel writer comes
along and says hey there's a lot of
these little things that go on in the
background when it comes to villains and
stuff and this is just one of those
things i mean when vendors came out and
he basically created the illuminati it
was this idea that the illuminati served
the purpose of operating in the
background without anybody really
knowing they were there this universal
bank is similar to like the hellfire
club it's similar to the secret avengers
for the time that they were there it's
really just one of these things where it
operates behind the scenes and it's
composed of people like ezekiel saying
the son of obadiah staying i think it is
like shenzhen harada the guy who runs
the yoshida corporation he's basically
silver samurai it's kingpin you know
it's sebastian shaw of the hellfire club
it's these extremely wealthy individuals
now they're all here talking to dario
agar but the reason why this meeting was
convened was actually for the purpose of
allowing somebody else to basically get
in here and to capture dario agar now
the person who comes in here and
basically assaults him is a woman by the
name of miss midas now ublie amanus is a
weird character i mean she's the
daughter of midas himself and minus was
literally a guy that had his namesake
where he had the midas touch everything
he touched physically turned to gold and
it didn't matter what it is whatever he
touched would turn to gold i think that
maybe thor's hammer was an exception but
honestly he was such an obscure
character you'd be hard-pressed to find
an instance you know midas fighting thor
i mean he was super obscure he was
really crazy really original sin was
like the biggest role he had in marvel
comics right but at the time or at least
as far as the story goes anyway the
capture of dario agar is for the purpose
of the fact that remember he's operating
with malikith for those of you guys who
are just joining us in the realm of
jason aaron's thor the way that he had
basically played this out a lot of this
went into the events before secret wars
and it just kind of kept on going like
most of the marvel stories did but it
was basically this scenario where
there's a company called roxanne oil
roxanne is a super seedy corporation i
mean they have their hands in everything
corruption gambling crime you know all
different kinds of stuff but as long as
it makes them money they don't really
care what it is they've got lawyers on
top of lawyers on top of lawyers that
will get them out of any legal problem
and if lawyers cannot get them out of
problems then they'll go through illegal
channels to make that happen but again
they're just a very seedy corporation
but dario agar is the guy who's running
the show here what happened was in the
realm of asgard with all the other
realms and everything in terms of their
mythology one of the dark elves named
malakith a long-time villain in the thor
mythos had basically begun the process
of going through and conquering all the
realms and the idea here was to
essentially and we'll get a little more
into this here in a second but the idea
was to basically go to roxanne oil and
to use roxanne oil's resources in
response roxanne said we'll provide you
with whatever you need tanks guns armor
the whole nine yards to conquer these
different rounds we'll give you what you
need but what we want is to be able to
mine all the rare minerals from these
realms so we can sell them at a premium
on earth because nobody would be able to
gain access to them otherwise you got to
keep in mind in the realm of the dwarves
that's where uber metal is that's the
material that forged thor's hammer and
so if roxanne oil shows up on earth and
says hey guys here's this material that
rivals adamantium and strength they
would make boatloads of money off it
because you'd have tanks you'd have guns
you'd have knives all of which are just
as durable as adamantium but also
possess the ability to basically harness
magic it'd be like everybody's running
around with their own version of thor's
hammer it'd be crazy in terms of what it
would be capable of but that was the
deal that roxanne oil struck now what we
also had was loki going on but we'll get
to him here in a second with regards to
jane foster's character again you know
one of the things that jason aaron
focuses on a lot of ways is kind of this
ongoing subplot that everybody's trying
to figure out who the new thor is and in
this instance we basically have shield
that takes jane foster prisoner and just
kind of you know really interrogates her
for a little while now of course they're
asking questions who's thor what do you
know about thor what can you tell us are
you thor and of course jane foster's
like this is ridiculous you know there's
no way that i'm thor i'm literally a
woman who's dying of cancer now in terms
of jane foster's character because a lot
of people have asked me about this how
is it that she's thor and she's dying of
cancer what happens is that jane foster
of course as a cancer patient undergoes
chemotherapy the issue is that whenever
she becomes thor it purges the
chemotherapy from her body and so when
she turns back into jane foster again
she's effectively set back to square one
not that her cancer goes into remission
while she stores it's basically that her
cancer is just incurable when she gets a
treatment the treatment's wiped away and
so her cancer just keeps progressing now
what this is jason aaron doing is
basically setting a ticking clock he's
saying it's only a matter of time before
jane foster will inevitably pass on and
then most likely odin's son will take
her place again going back to being thor
so it's really kind of him saying hey
this is just a cool experiment it might
last five years it might last ten years
but it's not going to last forever it'll
probably end when jason aaron's run on
thor ends to be quite frank that's
usually what a lot of writers do but for
the sake of this discussion we basically
have another character come along named
roz solomon now ross solomon again has
also been a huge part of the thor mythos
she's been around for quite some time
and in fact when jane foster thor first
showed up a lot of people thought it was
ross solomon just because of the fact
that she was a character that had this
kind of on-again off-again teasing of
romance between her and odin's son she
was a huge fan for quite some time and
so people figured if it was going to be
anybody it would be ross solomon because
she's the most likely person to be a
hero because she was such a huge you
know environmental advocate she's a
shield agent she has access to resources
she has the means to basically travel to
the moon if she wanted to and pick up
thor's hammer there was a lot of
speculation going on there and jason
aaron really played on that i mean it
was constantly being teased is that
possible but the fact remains here that
with ross solomon being a shield agent
she essentially shows up and says jane
foster you're free to go there's no way
you're possibly thor because remember
roz doesn't know that jane foster's thor
she has no clue i mean we as the reader
only recently found out around the time
the story was released we'd only
recently found out that jane foster was
thorn so basically no one knows the
truth of the matter now of course jane
foster basically grabs her hammer she
ends up taking over the hammer herself
but in the midst of all this we
essentially have ross solomon traveling
to the location of dario agar almost
immediately after he's taken by miss
midas and silver samurai and the result
of this is that ross solomon comes to
the realization that there is a plan
that's been enacted called the agar
imperative now the aggro imperative will
become prevalent here in a little bit
but it's basically like a doomsday plan
it's really all it is but at this point
we basically transitioned to loki
because keep in mind in volume one and
thunder and revenge loki had basically
killed or at least it looked like he had
killed all mother it looked like he had
killed the wife of odin and because of
this you know with freya basically being
incapacitated here there really doesn't
seem to be anybody or at least there
wasn't anybody who was running the
throne until you know borson had
basically taken over it now again borson
was this guy who was basically the
serpent he was the unknown brother of
odin that no one knew about and the
story fear itself actually introduced
him but over the course of marvel's
publication history he'd more or less
just become kind of like a general you
know a leader among the ranks of odin's
forces on asgard but you know with odin
essentially running the show and then
eventually being cast out and replaced
by freya what loki says is that because
freya was on the throne she was a a
caring leader she was basically a person
that looked out and said as asgard we
are despite it being self-appointed the
protector of all the realms we have to
protect all of them we have to make sure
that evil does not run amok in the
realms even if for no other reason than
to make sure that some force doesn't
rise up that can basically kill all of
us and so because of that what malikith
was basically looking for was to have
cole borson appointed as leader or to
have odin go back as leader and the
reason why was because their only
concern would be asgard and so by the
time malikith had gone on his campaign
began taking over all the nine realms by
the time the cold bore son or odin had
looked around and said hey we need to do
something it would have been too late
the forces of malikith with the help of
roxanne would have been bolstered to the
degree that there would have been
nothing that the asgardians could have
done and so loki says hey look i had to
make sure that malikith and his guys
trusted me i had to make sure that if i
told them i'm part of your dark council
they'll legitimately believe it and
killing you was the only way that it
could be done now of course we basically
have odin pushing his own energies into
freya in order to keep her alive and try
to bring her back but the idea here is
that this is really jason aaron saying
hey when it came to the idea of loki
killing freyja when we read through the
comic and it was like my god you know
loki killed his mom it wasn't him being
vindictive it wasn't loki being evil it
was loki trying to earn the trust of
malekith and uh and dario agar in order
to basically subvert them from within to
effectively work against them and cast
them out to protect asgard because keep
in mind when it comes to the character
of loki there are events like ragnarok
right you know where loki is basically
the one that ends up invading asgard and
tearing it all down but that's the fate
of loki whenever it comes to anybody
else who tries to attack asgard who
tries to tear it all down loki is almost
always one of the first people online to
say no that's my job
that's my purpose to take out asgard if
anybody's going to bring this kingdom
crashing down it's going to be me now
again because of the fact of this agar
imperative this is essentially a
scenario where we basically have agar
who effectively took roxanne island this
giant island that kind of floats up in
the sky and essentially said it so that
if he dies the island will come crashing
down into new york it'll literally just
kind of rise up into the sky and then
come crashing back down again and that's
really the whole basis here now that's
the whole protocol that's basically
being enacted by miss midas and by a
silver samurai now for a little bit here
we really just kind of get some fighting
going on i mean we get some threatening
from miss midas towards dario agar we
have silver samurai going against jane
foster thor there's not a whole lot
going on here but there are a few things
to take note of most notably the reason
why miss midas did this was for the
basis of the fact that she was just kind
of angry at the fact that agger was
working with malikith he was going to
take the resources of the 10 realms and
then use it for himself and what this
means is that because of the money that
he would have possessed assuming that
all this worked and he actually was able
to sell off these resources he would
have literally been able to come along
and just shut out everybody else i mean
kingpin would have gone broke the fisk
industries would have gone down yoshida
industries would have gone down midas
industries they all would have basically
been purchased become subsidiaries of
roxanne or they would have just been
pushed out to the point where they
couldn't make any money and they would
all go broke and so it's literally just
corporate espionage is really all this
is that's really what it comes down to
but the fact remains that in the midst
of all this with roxanne island
effectively floating above the sky the
question they have to ask jane foster
she has to ask herself do i really help
the leader of my greatest enemy if
roxanne oil is essentially working
alongside malikith to conquer the 10
realms to literally try to conquer
asgard is jane foster really going to
put herself in a position where she's
going to have to now help the leader of
roxanne oil in order to spare millions
of people who would be killed if he were
to die and roxanne island were to come
crashing down in new york and the answer
to that question is yes it's really one
of these things where she has to make a
small sacrifice now for the greater good
later on now that's why jason aaron's
stories are really cool i mean granted
this is really just kind of like a
filler volume so i mean it's not like
there's greatness going on here it's not
like people are gonna look at lords of
midgard and say this is one of the
greatest stories ever told is filler
content but it goes towards bolstering
the character and building the character
of jane foster when it comes to the idea
of jane versus odin's son i mean outside
the realm of the comic book stories
itself jane foster thor is outselling
odin's son thor by leaps and bounds it's
almost night and day and it's crazy how
popular she is right now but in terms of
the stories themselves odin's son was a
pretty two-dimensional character i mean
there wasn't a whole lot to him he would
show up he'd beat people up with his
hammer and then he would leave that was
really it i mean there weren't that many
great stories you know off the top of my
head the only stories that really stood
out when it came to odin's son's
character was basically everything
written by jason aaron
from god butcher going forward his story
saw these huge three-dimensional shifts
in character to where he was far more
interesting than he had ever been but by
that point it was too little too late
you know i mean you had a few things
like thor ragnarok you know you had j
michael strzenski's thor which is pretty
cool and in truth if i ever decide to
start thor comics i'll probably pick up
with uh ragnarok and then just start
working forward from strazinski's thor
like i did with the incredible hulk and
greg paxtron but the idea here is that
jane foster's not that way jane foster's
conflicted she struggles she's an
average human being who was imbued with
the power of thor odin's son was always
the son of odin i mean he was born the
son of odin he was cocky he was arrogant
he was cast out his consciousness was
forced into the body of a guy named
donald blake and he had to rediscover
himself which is how we were introduced
to thorne marvel comics but he was
always the son of odin he never really
had to deal with like what it meant to
really understand humanity on a
fundamental scale because he's not human
he wasn't born human with jane foster
it's very much the opposite she's a
woman dying of cancer so she's basically
facing her death every single day she's
a woman that realizes every time she
becomes thor it continues her path
towards dying that it doesn't stave it
off now the question is why didn't she
just stay thor forever well in truth it
would just kind of take away from the
story if she did but it creates a very
dynamic situation it creates some really
strong dichotomies between being a god
and being a human and what it means for
the character and so because of that you
know with her sitting down and her
basically saying i've got to save the
guy that is basically going to try to
conquer asgard it prolongs the conflict
it kind of keeps things going but at the
same time it also creates a cool
situation because when she arrives on
the scene her arrival takes place at the
same time that daario agar basically
turns into his minotaur form now for
those of you guys who don't know a whole
lot about dario agar he's basically a
guy that has kind of this weird history
but essentially he was a kid at nine
years old saw his family killed prayed
to a minotaur a minotaur statue in a
cave really and the result was that he
was imbued with the ability to become a
minotaur at will now of course he got
his revenge on pirates and so on and so
forth but it created the situation where
he was more or less this physical
equivalent to thor in a lot of ways
where they would fight but it was also
this situation where he kind of had his
hulk-esque persona it was kind of like a
hulk transformation for the character of
dario aguero but it was basically a way
to take this ceo guy who could be more
than just some face of a very seedy
company and actually make him a
dangerous individual so metaphorically
it's kind of like an outward
manifestation of the danger that roxanne
represents but you know when jane foster
shows up of course it's kind of the
battle between the two of them but we
also have miss midas effectively loading
a bullet with her father's blood now
again ouglier does not have the
irradiated blood that her father did so
she cannot physically touch things and
turn them to gold but because of the
fact that her father died because she
preserved a fragment of his blood when
the original sin event happened and she
basically took over her father's role we
didn't know what the future held for her
character and in fact really a lot of us
just didn't really care but
and i don't mean to sound cynical here
it's just that nobody really sat down
and said man i really can't wait to see
what happens with the midas corporation
it was just one of those things that
nobody ever thought about which actually
you know kudos to jason aaron for using
her in such an interesting way but
because of the fact that her father's
blood was irradiated she was basically
able to fire a bullet off and she
essentially went to go shoot dario agar
with the idea that if he dies it'll
bring everything crashing down now the
larger goal that she has i mean when it
comes to miss minus the bigger goal she
has is yeah a few million people are
going to die she doesn't care about that
what she does care about is the fact
that roxanne oil is a publicly traded
company which means that if roxanne
island comes crashing down in new york
investors people who have money in the
company are going to pull out and its
shares are going to be virtually
worthless and the company's going to go
under so it's really just a way to kill
dario agar which would result in the
destruction of roxanne's own company it
would just bring it all crashing down
now here's the irony of all this is that
despite the fact that they are mortal
enemies jane foster and miss midas are
basically working for the same goal
they're just going about it two
different ways they both want to bring
roxanne oil down and if this was any
other situation if it was any other
scenario if you know roxanne island was
just sitting out in the pacific
somewhere jane foster probably would
have let dario agar die she probably
would have been like well your time's up
man sorry about your luck but because of
the fact that it would jeopardize
millions of innocent lives where miss
midas is like hey let's just go ahead
and kill him jane foster steps up and
catches the bullet now the response here
is that because of the fact that the
bullet again has the blood of dr midas
and it'll turn anything it touches into
gold it starts doing that with jane
foster to a degree now this is where
things get crazy because then we
suddenly have jane foster showing up to
help thor and this is where jason aaron
again started saying hey guys like are
we sure that jane foster's thor i know
you think she's thor but do we know for
a fact that she's actually thor again we
know right now jane foster is thor and
in fact that gets revealed at the end of
all this but with the actual jane foster
showing up jane foster thor looks at her
says who the hell are you like
how are you here because you know
you're me
i'm jane foster how do we square this
circle now really before any questions
are asked and even then you know these
shield agents that are here that are
still trying to figure out what the
connection is between jane foster and
thor there's kind of like well if
they're both here in the same place and
it's clear that jane foster isn't thor
dr jane foster being a doctor for so
long basically you know plucks the
bullet out of thor and is like you are
cool you are healed the problem with
this is that roxanne island crashes into
a shield helicarrier and it just sends
everything sort of awry now under normal
circumstances this wouldn't be a huge
deal but it becomes a huge deal and the
reason why is because in the midst of
everything you know shaking rattling
kind of panicking and going awry we
suddenly have jane foster accidentally
dropping the bullet that landed in
thor's hand and so what this does is it
turns the entirety of roxanne island and
the gold and it literally just brings it
crashing down now the reason for this is
just simple gravity and weight that's
really all it is i mean the idea that
the island is now made of gold means the
gravitational pull of the planet it's
far more intense than it normally would
have been gold is a lot heavier than
rocks and soil and so on and so forth
and so because of that it just comes
crashing down now of course jane foster
is able to keep this from happening jane
foster at least seems to be what amounts
to destroy the island when she basically
takes it and throws it into the sun
which is really kind of cool here but as
a follow-up to this as the reader
questions were lingering i mean you have
dario aguero who's basically taken or at
least it seems like he's gonna be taken
by shield but in the end lawyers more or
less get him out but the question that
people had that we as the reader had is
if we have jane foster here and we have
thor here then who the hell is thor and
this is when we basically learned that
this physical manifestation of jane
foster was created by the hammer it was
established by the hammer the hammer
basically created this physical
construct of jane foster and that's what
let everybody know what's going on now
what also happened here is that thor
basically sits down with ross solomon
and says no no that was a manifestation
of the hammer i am jane foster and this
is when thor reveals her true identity
to ross solomon and this was really kind
of like wow this is crazy now from here
this is basically jason aaron moving
into the process of revealing that the
hammer was alive because again people
didn't really know what was going on and
even ross solomon asked the question if
the hammer of his own volition made a
construct of jane foster in order to
throw shield off your scent as well as
allow you to be treated without anybody
asking questions then does that mean the
hammer is alive and that's when the
hammer grabs jane foster and they whisk
off and that's when we get into my video
on the untold origin of mjolnir so for
those of you guys who are wondering how
these two dots get connected those of
you guys who were wondering how we got
from point a to point b with regards to
what at least the time was believed to
be lords of midgard and then the story
of the untold origin of thor's hammer
that's how we got here but again that
was my mistake you know i i screwed up
with regards to the titling what i think
i'm going to do as well is maybe start a
thor playlist the only problem that with
doing that right now is it'd be kind of
jumping the gun just because of the fact
that at the moment i probably won't
really be covering a lot of thor's stuff
until we get around to like the release
of ragnarok and that doesn't come out
until november so you know there'll be a
huge thor dumping around that time but
until then i think i might just go ahead
and toss this into the all new all
different marvel playlists that's down
in the description if you guys are
interested in seeing it but yeah i mean
again this is really just kind of jason
aaron filling things it's really him
just saying hey guys we got to get from
point a to point b so here's the bridge
that we use here's how we get from those
two spots and again from that point
going forward really from the untold
origin of mjolnir going forward that's
where things get cool plus we also have
unworthy thor which is amazing but
enough rambling for me
okay so getting into uh the asgard shiar
war with regards to the mighty thor this
is a pretty solid story something else
to keep in mind this also seems to take
place before the events of secret empire
before anything happened in the main
secret empire story so this takes place
before secret empire number zero and the
free comic book day issue and number one
all the way up to the present day that
takes place before all that stuff but
the whole set of events that goes on
here is actually pretty wild because
this gives us a lot more insight into
the shiar empire than we previously had
before now a little bit of explanation
here for those of you guys who are just
now getting into thor and really just
now getting into marvel comics uh the
shia empire is a race that dates back
quite some time and it really all you
know goes all the way back to when chris
claremont was writing the x-men then he
was looking to introduce the phoenix
force and the idea was that the shia
empire isn't like an empire like
humanity right like the human race could
be considered an empire it's a very
fledgling empire but it could be
considered an empire the difference is
that unlike the badoon or unlike the
scrolls or the cree or something like
that the shiar is an amalgamation of
races it's a multitude of different
races that have all come together under
a single banner of the shiar now more
often than not the reason this is done
is because of the fact that there's
protection as part of the shiar empire
and that protection comes in the form of
the shia imperial guard when it comes to
their ranks when it comes to like their
governing body there's the magistrates
or the emperor whatever you want to call
it the emperor empress ah the ones that
are basically running the show at this
point in time in marvel comics uh it's
actually gladiator and we'll get into
him here in a second because he's a
pretty powerful character the other half
of this is that you have the imperial
guard which is basically the toughest
members of the of the shia race of the
shia empire that all gather together as
their singular leader now you've got
like an inner group of the imperial
guard which is like the very top people
but the imperial guard's pretty large in
size in terms of uh how it functions and
what it does because it's basically like
their their core military it's basically
like the best of their military might i
mean they have like an armada they've
got ships all kinds of cool stuff but
the imperial guard is what you call in
when things really hit the fan and so
whenever you read a story from marvel
comics where it's like oh they're
sending in the imperial guard that means
things are really gonna pop off now in
the case of gladiator because he's
actually running the show here it's
really curious as to why it is he shows
up on the steps of asgardia now the
reason why this is kind of cool is
because it actually gives us a couple
characters fighting that we never really
seek engage in conflict uh the first one
is heimdall and the second one of course
is gladiator himself now heimdall
functions very much in marvel comics the
same way he does in the marvel cinematic
universe the difference here is
basically how they look but in terms of
his form and function he just sees
virtually everything but the funny thing
about this is that there's this question
that's kind of asked by jason aaron of
if he's an asgardian that means that he
has to breathe that means that he has to
eat it means that he has vulnerabilities
just like virtually anybody else albeit
enhance durability and enhanced skills
and so where he's the one that sees
pretty much everything happening if he
functions like a normal being then what
happens if he blinks and that's the
coolest thing is because in that instant
in that fraction of a second when he
blinks if someone's fast enough they can
dart from one side of the universe to
the other and that's exactly what
happens here in that fraction of a
moment when heimdall blinks gladiator
arrives now the cool thing about
gladiator is that he's very much like
marvel's version of superman and marvel
has a lot of those i mean in truth when
it comes to like those legacy characters
there's no possible way marvel could
make a character that has a cape and
that can fly and that has that that's
super strong without having the same
powers of superman they're basically
just the foundation of virtually all
abilities i mean superman's powers
aren't really unique anymore the only
ones that stand out are like his super
breath his heat vision and even then you
know those aspects of his character are
kind of spread out i mean it's it's
superman i mean you know no one's gonna
say superman falls rank and file with
every other superhero ever it's superman
it's the superhero so the cool thing
here is that gladiator when it comes to
his abilities he's extremely powerful i
mean he's extremely strong he's
extremely durable he has you know laser
vision and all kinds of cool stuff but
his powers are intertwined directly with
his confidence so if he engages in a
conflict and he starts losing and his
confidence starts to wane his powers
will go with it and so it was really
kind of a cool scenario but outside of
that one caveat he is a force to be
reckoned with when it comes down to it
if gladiator jumps into the conflict
then that means whoever it is that he's
facing against barring you know bargain
being like thanos or like galactus or
somebody like that they're probably
gonna be done but the whole idea of him
arriving here is for the purpose of
actually taking jane foster herself now
of course what ends up happening is that
where heimdall is the eyes and ears he's
also the first line of protection uh
with asgard and so with gladiator
overpowering heimdall this says
something because remember if heimdall
heimdall's supposed to be the first line
of protection then that means that he's
the one that comes before odin and he
comes before thor he's really one of the
most powerful beings in asgard but in
the middle of all this because of the
fact that the imperial guard is just
kind of tearing everything apart trying
to find thor ultimately jane foster
reveals herself and in that moment she's
essentially taken by gladiator and
brought before those individuals who
sent gladiator to asgard in the first
place which are revealed to be none
other than shara and ki3 now here's the
cool thing about this this is why i say
we get a lot more expansion on the the
shia race than we ever really did before
sharon k3 is very akin to to thor and
odin just because of the fact that in
that part of the world there are people
that worship thor and odin they follow
that belief system that there's odin and
there's the sun thor and there's loki
the god of mischief and so on and so
forth with this the shia look at shari
and k3 much the same way the difference
here is that much like thor and odin
shara and k3 are very much real and
they're basically the gods of the shia
race and that's a cool thing here
because remember one of the things that
was established in jason aaron's thor
god of thunder storyline was the idea of
gods the idea that there is this great
big huge pantheon every planet has its
own gods every universe has gods and
truth the question that really comes out
of that is which came first the chicken
or the egg is it the gods who arrived on
the planet and they were viewed as gods
by people who worship them or were the
gods given life by virtue of the worship
that people gave them and so that's the
whole basis behind this this particular
scenario but in this instance it's
really more of the idea that shara and
ke3 are basically engaging in this
challenge of the gods to basically show
which god is the greater is it thor or
is it shara and k3 now the reason behind
this we don't really know and actually
we won't find out here for a little bit
but transitioning back to asgard what we
do here is we actually pick up with sif
and we pick up with colt now cole borson
is a guy that we will actually talk
about once we get around to uh november
with regards to our whole run on thor
fear itself all that kind of good stuff
but the introduction of coal was part
and parcel to fear itself and what it
basically revealed is that odin had a
third brother that nobody knew about
that for years and years and years it
was believed that the the the odin force
was basically just the amalgamation of
the life energies of odin's brothers and
himself combined into a singular being
that allowed him to do a wide array of
different things the introduction of
coal also came with him basically having
his own hammers and these hammers were
given to different people across the
marvel universe each one pertaining to a
particular group of group of superheroes
so like juggernaut for example had a
hammer and he ended up going against the
x-men and so that's the kind of cool
scenario that we saw because dude when
juggernaut has the hammer it is amazing
it's one of the coolest things ever fear
itself was an amazing storyline when it
came to thor one of my absolute
favorites but the overarching gist here
is that because cold bore sun was
effectively defeated by a large part of
the superhero community this led to coal
more or less just kind of being being
resigned to living in asgard proper now
the difference here is that going into
the events of siege and going into these
stories where it basically saw you know
saw asgard destroyed and then eventually
reformed by odin himself with the injury
of the mother of thor basically having
happened at the beginning of the story
which again we covered all that stuff uh
it ultimately led to odin basically
vacating his position as king of vasgard
more or less and then kolberson taking
up his place as regent and what this
means is that cole borson has all the
authority of odin meaning when he speaks
he speaks on behalf of odin now the
reason why this is important is because
of the fact that odin did not remove
himself as king and make cole king in
his place because now that would mean
that coal has the power of a king he can
reject odin's claim to the throne if
odin ever decided to come back that's
not the case instead what it means is
that odin can return at any time and
call has to give up his seat now if he
refused i mean it wouldn't matter odin
would just question him and then he
would just take his seat back but the
fact remains when it comes to like
proper policy when it comes to politics
that's basically what it is that's going
on here the other half of this is that
cole borson hates thor call is a is a
reflection of a lot of the fans out
there who do not like jane foster and
that's one of the cool things about uh
jason aaron's run on fork is because he
recognizes there are people out there
who just don't like jane foster to them
odin's son is the only thor and they're
not wrong it's their personal opinion
and there's nothing wrong with them for
having that opinion but jason aaron
recognizes that now jane foster's thor
and we get those stories and we will get
those stories until odin's son gets his
hammer back we know that's gonna happen
but the cool thing is we get these
really interesting stories in the
interim but the funny thing about siff
in this particular situation is that she
actually goads cola borson what she does
is she says look we know you don't like
this new thor we know you don't like her
you don't think she's worthy of the
hammer you believe that only the odin
family line should be the ones to be
able to wield it and so the question i
have is this if asgard has been left in
ruins by the shiar who are you going to
allow to carry the glory of defeating
the shia empire in return for their
actions are you gonna let thor get that
glory or are you gonna be the one to do
it and so at that point it's just a
matter of honor at that point it's just
a matter of i will not let thor take the
glory of this battlefield today
i will be the one to win you know to
keep the honor of the odin family and so
that's the cool thing here is basically
just kind of praying on the honor that
he has basically saying look i know that
that for you it's family first so are
you going to stick up for your family or
are you going to let somebody walk in
and capture this glory here now the
other half of this is the actual
challenge of the gods and it's actually
kind of interesting the way this works
because what jason aaron seems to be
toying on here is the idea that shara
and ki3 are not the embodiment of
prayers of the shiar it's really just a
matter of who is it the various members
of the shia race will pray to in their
time of dire need and so the goal is to
basically gain points through prayers
and it's kind of a funny scenario
because the way they do this is
instituting like mass casualties doing
things like creating tidal waves and
these natural disasters and all these
huge conflicts and it's interesting
because what they're really doing here
is they're saying it's not a matter of
whether or not jane foster saves the day
it's a matter of when they're fleeing
for their lives who are they praying to
save them or who are they praying to to
save them are they praying to us shara
and ke3 or are they praying to thor and
so again it's kind of a cool scenario
because it's one of these situations
where the more thor acts the more people
become aware of who she is and so it's
really kind of a cool scenario because
she goes through and she begins earning
the adoration of all these members of
the shia race who stopped you know
praying to shara and keith and start
praying to thor now the the human
element of jane foster really comes into
play when she basically says no don't
pray to me i'm just doing what i'm
supposed to do i'm just helping you guys
and really for the people who don't like
jane foster that will fan them on even
further in their hatred for jane foster
but you know it's still kind of an
interesting scenario because if it was
odin's son it really kind of depends on
the writer i mean some writers most
likely jason aaron would have been like
oh it's not necessary but if you have
alcohol i'll take some of that you know
but with regards to jane foster's not
that way she's very human she's very
simple in terms of how she views the
world we could literally have that
discussion we could really say who was
working to make the make the universe a
better place was it odin's son or was it
jane foster because in truth they both
pretty much did the same thing odin's
son fought some amazing and epic battles
he relished in the conflict he enjoyed
the the thrill of the hunt so to speak
but at the end of the day he was
fighting bad guys that wanted to destroy
the earth jane foster doesn't really
relish in the the glory of battle she
doesn't really live to win the day but
she fights against bad guys and she
saves the world so it really kind of
creates this interesting scenario but in
every single instance every single one
of these tests whether it be some comet
you know that's just like spiraling
across the universe whether it's you
know some crazy person who's going to
sacrifice their child in the name of
shara and k3 each time jane foster steps
in he's basically able to save these
people or at least save them as best she
can and each time she ends up gaining
more prayers gaining more adoration now
in truth at the end of the day none of
it really matters because of course we
end up having this massive battle in
space between uh cole bourson and the
shiar empire that's not wildly important
but it is kind of interesting to see i
mean it's something to keep us
entertained and keep us a little more
interested but we actually jump back a
little bit jump back about a few days
before any of this took place and we
actually ended up finding out this
entire scenario was basically goaded by
loki himself now something to keep in
mind when it comes to jason aaron's run
on the mighty thor he's basically been
telling us there's a much bigger picture
a much bigger game that loki's playing
we don't know what it is but we know
that there's a plan in place loki's
doing all these things because it's all
far all part of a plan he's not just
running around instigating chaos you
know seeding conflict and reaping war
it's not that way instead he's going
through a plan it's something that he's
basically set up we just don't really
know what it is and so these little
things that come in here and there every
time we see them we have to ask the
question is loki doing this because he's
just being a dick
or is loki doing it because it's all
part of the plan and so again it's kind
of an interesting scenario but jumping
back into jane foster really she just
ends up having enough of this massive
conflict ends up having enough of this
battle and so what ends up happening is
she actually turns on shara in k3
attempts to basically end the conflict
but what we end up learning here is that
when it comes to like this scoreboard
jane foster lost by like an insane
margin i mean she was just readily
stomped by a country mile when it came
to like garnering prayers because shara
and k3 are just too entrenched into the
shia race the shia race has been
worshiping them for too long it's the
only gods that they know of the only
gods that they care about they're too
intertwined when it comes to the shia
race itself but jane foster actually
ends up winning and the reason why is
because she's awarded bonus points
because of the fact that she inspired
other gods to fight on her behalf most
notably even if it's only through wrath
even if it's only through anger and
absolute hatred cole borson basically
fought the shiar empire on behalf of
jane foster he fought the other side of
the battle and that's why i say that's
kind of significant but not the most
important thing ever it's the way in
which she ends up basically you know
coming out on top of the conflict but
the cool thing about this is that in the
face of almost guaranteed defeat at the
hands of jane foster herself what is up
happening is shara and k3 actually
invoke the phoenix force now the phoenix
force is an interesting concept in the
realm of marvel comics because one this
is the first time or at least that we're
aware of because i don't know where this
fits chronologically in relation to like
thanos or the jean grey solo series but
uh you know we can just kind of assume
this is one of the first times that we
see the phoenix force in all new all
different marvel and it's cool to see
because of the fact that the phoenix has
existed all around marvel comics for
quite some time now something that i
want to point out here and something
that i want to talk about here for a
second was the question that we brought
up during our thanos video one of the
things that i have pointed out is that
historically speaking there's only ever
been one host for the phoenix force at
any one particular time which is to say
there's only ever been one instance
where the phoenix shows up and then
gives somebody his powers there have
been people like rachel summers who were
time displaced and they had the powers
of the phoenix but the phoenix whenever
it shows up says you as an individual
are now my avatar the only real
exception to that came with avengers
versus x-men and that was only because
of the fact they tried to destroy the
phoenix force and ended up dispersing
among five people but the phoenix did
not choose to go into those five people
it was just kind of destroyed or at
least attacked by tony stark which led
to it splitting up into five different
people what we ended up having with the
thanos story at least one of the things
that i brought up is that by the time we
finish that story uh the all-new younger
version of jean grey thane himself and
then of course quentin choir as we'll
see in the story all become hosts for
the phoenix and it doesn't usually work
that way the phoenix force is a
multiversal entity or kind of like an
omniversal entity and what that means is
that much like you know the one above
all or the living tribunal there's only
one phoenix force throughout the
multiverse the difference is that the
phoenix force will manifest itself in
different universes sometimes all the
universes at the same time other times
only one universe at a time but the
phoenix will only ever usually choose
one host for itself in any one
particular universe what we're seeing
here with regards to the younger version
of jean grey with uh with thane the son
of thanos with quentin choir here this
is new this is something that we haven't
really seen before or if we have i've
never seen it before having multiple
hosts for the phoenix force who've all
gained the power of the phoenix around
the same time in a single continuity of
a story now again we don't really know
where like thanos resides we don't
really know the end result of this j or
of this uh jean grey story and we don't
really know where like this resides in
continuity they could just happen one
after the other it could simply just be
that within the realm of all new all
different marvel's continuity quentin
choir becomes the host for the phoenix
then it leaves him and then it goes to
thane then it leaves spain and then it
appears to jean grey that's entirely
possible we simply just don't know yet
at this point we're waiting for the
stories to flesh out we're waiting to
see where they end up and then we'll be
able to kind of bring them together and
you know once we see like middle rows
like for example if we have a big
crossover event if it's like the the
omega issue of secret empire the 11th
issue because it's 11 issues now if it's
like 11 the 11th issue of secret empire
and like quentin choir and thane and
jean grey are all there and they all
have the power of the phoenix force then
that would give us an answer to the
question that we're looking for but for
right now we don't really have a
definitive answer but essentially
because of the fact that shara and k3
are facing almost imminent destruction
they basically bring the phoenix force
back out they effectively resurrect it
now this is kind of a cool scenario
because for those individuals who love
odin's son and those individuals who are
not really partial to jane foster this
is interesting because jane foster's
never fought the phoenix force before
and the phoenix is not an entity that
you can fight through physical contact
it doesn't work that way it's it's
non-corporeal you know for all the good
it'll do to hit the phoenix force with a
hammer she might as well be swinging its
smoke and so it's really kind of a cool
scenario because we're talking about a
level of power that's so extreme even if
jane foster was able to hit it with a
hammer it wouldn't do any good and so
what ends up happening is we end up
having uh having jane foster thor
actually travel back to earth and grab
quentin choir and bring him with her to
the battlefield ultimately to deal with
the phoenix force proper now the reason
why this matters is for a couple things
the first is that it's well known that
writer jason aaron loves quentin choir
and i'm really excited to see what his
solo series is about but two it's not
the first time that clinton choir and
the phoenix force have gone hand in hand
and the story that we did from new x-men
which was called here comes tomorrow i
think it was it dealt with the idea of
like jean grey the full encompassing
power of what she does as the phoenix
but we saw all these different alternate
reality hosts of the phoenix force which
is why i say the phoenix manifests in a
multitude of different realities but we
saw all these different alternate
reality hosts of the phoenix force one
of whom was quentin choir and so the
idea is that quentin whether it's in an
alternate universe or whether it's in
the main marvel universe will at some
point become a host for the phoenix
force just because of the fact that
quentin choir is an omega level telepath
the term omega level when it comes to
mutants is just kind of like this
general phrase this uh somewhat vague
little enigmatic phrase but it basically
means that that's the the highest level
of power that any one particular mutant
can have that's really kind of a cool
scenario because jane foster's actually
yanked into the white hot room of the
phoenix by the phoenix entity itself now
again the white hot room is kind of like
this way station it's kind of this place
this basically the core center of the
multiverse is the best way that i can
describe it this is one of the weird
things about marvel comics different
locations are depicted different ways
some people say the white hot room is
the way station you travel to before you
go to the afterlife some people say the
white hot room is basically where the
current host of the phoenix force
resides while it's doing whatever the
phoenix force you know is doing uh
different people different writers
depicted different ways but uh on the
whole the white hot room is usually
where a person's conscious mind goes
when the phoenix wants to talk to it
just because of the fact that the
phoenix cannot commune with a person
through traditional means meaning the
phoenix can't talk like a normal human
being it has to take a host in order to
be able to pull that off and so the idea
is that it basically talks to jane
foster and it actually makes fun of her
a little bit he says look you fancy
yourself a god with your little hammer
and you're riding around with your
little armor you know you know nothing
of the term you know nothing of the
phrase god i am the very manifestation
of all life that will love will ever
exist and that has has ever existed i
serve the singular purpose of destroying
all things if i wanted to i could snuff
you out of existence right now and
that's 100 true if the phoenix force
wanted to get rid of jane foster thor
she would be gone and that's all there
is to it and so ultimately you know what
she ends up realizing and it's kind of a
caveat that jason aaron uses here but
what jane foster does is actually
manifest her hammer inside the white hot
room now in truth i don't really know
how it is this happens the hammer is a
physical object right now they're inside
the mind of or really inside the phoenix
force itself you know really kind of
inside the phoenix force's own mind so
to speak there's no real definitive
answer given here it's kind of cloak and
dagger maybe it's one of those things
that will be explained later on or maybe
it'll be left ambiguous forever but
attacking the phoenix force from the
inside is tantamount to the scene from
old man logan when old man hulk
swallowed wolverine and wolverine killed
him from the inside out uh that's
basically what it was that happened here
in addition to this when quentin choir
finally absorbs the phoenix entity unto
itself and becomes its new host odin's
son arrives just in time to miss the
battle
just in time to catch the tail end of it
all so again it's kind of an interesting
situation just because of the fact that
jane foster has more or less proved that
she is a legitimate god among all the
other gods that exist out there or
really the concept of thor is a
legitimate god when it stands a test of
time of what it is that they're capable
of what we also end up having is of
course you know this revelation that
this is the reason why it is odin's son
and jane foster both end up traveling
back to earth which leads them into uh
leads them into the secret empire
conflict and so what seems to be taking
place here is that jason aaron is
basically moving away from the direction
of focusing on jane foster thor and
odin's son in his thor run and focusing
on whoever it is the all-new ultimate
thor is and so again it's kind of a cool
scenario i'm not gonna swear to that but
that seems to be what it is that's
happening uh with regards to the thor
stories
so the story of war thor is actually
really interesting and it's really
really cool because this gives us a
version of thor that we haven't
necessarily seen before but a lot of
this is really just sort of up to
interpretation in a lot of ways too and
the reason i say that is because we
covered thor's the other day and we
basically sat down and we looked at this
idea of the hammer that belonged to
ultimate thor and what it was that
happened to the hammer now the weird
thing about this is that over the years
ultimate thor's hammer had kind of
received this this sort of bouncing
around in the sense that it was
destroyed it was remade different things
like that there was one point where he
actually got this sort of you know
traditional mjolnir that we see in the
main marvel universe not the exact same
one but something similar to it but the
idea was that in the thor's storyline
from secret wars that ultimate thor was
one of these individuals who served as
dr doom's uh police force basically and
what had happened was that in this
massive brawl among these different
versions of thor that the ultimate
hammer had left the secret wars universe
and was either transported throughout
all space and time or just transported
into the past or something along those
lines but ended up in asgard it
basically broke through the dimensional
barriers and ended up in this pocket
dimension of asgard now in truth that
should not have been allowed to happen
the entire basis behind secret wars was
that all conceivable universes and all
spaces dimensions the whole you know all
that stuff those were all destroyed in
the collapse of the multiverse
everything was gone and the only chunk
of existence that was left was battle
world so again it kind of fit into a
weird situation but this gives us an
update in terms of what's going on in
the sense of what this hammer's capable
of and what it can do now one thing to
keep in mind is there are
two schools of thought that are
currently floating around right now in
terms of the nature of this hammer the
school of thought that i ascribe to is
that it's the hammer that originally
belonged to ultimate thor but there is a
school of thought that also believes
that this hammer was used by ultimate
thor but was actually forged by dr doom
during the events of battle world as far
as i'm aware we're not explicitly told
if that's true in terms of which version
of the hammer this is all we know is
that it's a hammer that does not have a
worthiness enchantment and as we go
through this we'll actually find out
this hammer is almost identical in terms
of what it can do to the actual hammer
of thor but the other half of this is
that for those of you guys who are just
now joining us we are basically in the
midst of what's called the war of realms
and the idea here is that this is
essentially a being named malakith the
accursed trying to conquer all things in
existence that's basically what it is
now malachithia curse is a really cool
villain he's had the casket of ancient
winners but he's always been this sort
of background villain malikith was
always around there somewhere in some
form or fashion what war of the realms
does is it actually brings him to full
focus and essentially what he's been
doing is traveling around the various
realms of asgard and recruiting
different people to his cause initially
it was the frost giants then it became
the trolls and it became all these
different groups who rallied to malikith
knowing that malikith probably had the
wherewithal to win the conflict and the
reason for that is the other half of the
equation because while malikith was
traveling around and trying to conquer
everything everybody looked to asgard as
the people who would save them the
problem is that asgard had a lot of
inner turmoil because there was this
huge civil war going on in terms of
whether or not jane foster was actually
thor and so because that it led to like
odin taking sides against jane foster it
led to odin's wife freya going on the
side of jane foster and it led to this
great big huge conflict and so because
of this it allowed malikith the curse to
begin the process of going through and
just conquering all these different
realms with almost no one to stand in
his way now in this instance what this
does is it picks up with the aftermath
of the death of the light elves which
are one of the various race of elves
that exists within the asgardian mythos
and the idea was that the the light owls
were one of the first groups that
malikith took out just because the light
elves and the dark elves are mortal
enemies and so with the lidells being
pushed to the brink of extinction what
they had done is they had taken up
residence with the dwarves now the
dwarves are extremely important in
asgardian mythos the reason for this is
because of the fact that the dwarves are
basically the greatest craftsmen in all
of the asgardian realms they're the ones
that forged the hammer of thor now it's
kind of a funny thing here because we
actually pick up with uh wolfstag with
ross solomon and with the queen of the
white house and the cool thing about
this is that roz solomon was originally
a character who was introduced as just
this random shield agent and it was
actually this girl who had this desire
to basically go on a date with thor
which he granted to her
odin's son went on a date with ross
solomon but ever since then she's always
been kind of this recurring supporting
character but she is quite versed in the
asgardian mythos just because of the
fact that she's traveled around and seen
a lot of these different things but
volkstag himself is also a really kindly
guy who's also like a force to be
reckoned with because in truth he's one
of the warriors three that exists inside
of the main marvel universe and he's one
of the most capable warriors that exist
out there one of the bravest men around
the problem with the war of realms is
that it takes its toll in every
conceivable way physically because of
the loss of life because people who have
to fight over and over and over again
simply to just survive but it also takes
a psychological toll and the reason for
this is because volstag of course
spending time with these uh these light
elf children is basically met with the
arrival of the forces of certain that
immediately show up in the land of the
dwarves and start tearing everything to
pieces the problem with this is that the
parents of these light elves are all
killed the parents of these children are
all totally destroyed and it leaves
volstag in a situation where he's just
kind of required to take care of him as
best he can and sort of go through there
and and call it a day the issue is that
as he makes his way through there and as
these forces of certain basically begin
to emerge and continue wreaking all this
havoc they end up killing the kids now
this is when this psychological break
happens in the mind of volstag while he
has seen a multitude of conflicts a
multitude of battles and a multitude of
wars it's one thing to basically fight
against an enemy to eliminate them in
their entirety and it's another to stand
there and be helpless in the face of
loss of life and that's why this is so
huge is because he literally just
experiences this sort of psychic break i
mean it just cracks him almost in two
and so in response to this he does the
only thing he can do he literally seeks
out the ultimate hammer and picks it up
now remember when the ultimate hammer
crash landed in old asgard during the
events of thor's it was basically
safeguarded it was this idea that no
one's gonna pick it up no one's gonna go
and take it no one's gonna use it
because no one really knows how it works
this whole conflict this whole idea of
whether or not jane foster's worthy has
thrown into sharp relief the idea that
just because a person picks up the
hammer of odin does not mean that
everyone in asgard is going to believe
that person is thor and so because of
that people do not want to experience
yet another civil war within asgard
going on at the same time as the first
and so what they ended up doing was say
this is all hands off now of course the
idea was that odin son himself would be
the one who would maintain the hammer
the problem with this is that when jane
foster went to him and basically said
hey i am currently thor i'm the one who
was able to pick up your hammer it was
sort of a betrayal for odin's son in the
sense that their relationship had gone
back you know both his friends and even
his people who were an item at one time
it had gone back for quite some time and
for odin's son it was this idea that if
jane foster was going to become the new
thor the very least she could do is tell
him if only out of just respect for the
legacy that he carried the fact that she
hid it means there's a lack of trust
there and in that belief of a lack of
trust odin's son just kind of looked at
her with a skewed eye and so again this
creates this whole huge inner turmoil
because with war thor showing up he goes
to town and the reason for this is
because he shows up in this camp these
armies of certain forces and just
obliterate i mean it's one of the most
spectacular displays of absolute
decimation that i've ever seen but
notice this this is not volstag in his
traditional sense he's kindly he's more
of a jovial character as opposed to like
this battle-hardened everything has to
die kind of character now the other half
of this is that his path of destruction
is being monitored by amor the
enchantress and eulek king of the trolls
now these are two of the most powerful
beings in all of asgard trying to take
out war thor none of it works now what
this does is this hits home at the
nature of the ultimate hammer of thor in
the ultimate universe the hammer was
originally tech based over the course of
the years it almost seemed as though the
hammer was moving up to becoming almost
equivalent to the hammer of thor in the
main marvel universe but it was never on
that level it was basically a tech based
hammer the issue with this is that this
is why i say this seems to ascribe to
the idea that the hammer as it exists
now was forged by dr doom during the
events of battle world when the thor
core was being formed because we
basically end up seeing a display of
power that we've never seen before the
ability of the hammer to deflect blast
to basically eliminate magics in a way
that we hadn't seen before and so again
that's why it looks as though it's a
hammer forged by doctor doom but we're
not explicitly told that that's the case
but regardless of the circumstances even
with him having this hammer whether he
has it or not volstag is still a match
for almost anybody out there just
because of how strong he is he almost
kills both enchantress and eulek it's
not until enchantress uses their
abilities and basically summons the
black bifrost which is to say their own
teleportation system and gets them out
of there that she manages to survive the
experience but within volstag himself
there's a sort of inner turmoil this
idea that he realizes something's off
now what this all seems to do is hit at
home to the very nature of the hammers
themselves because remember for years
and years and years and years it was
this idea that thor's hammer was just a
hammer something he picked up and had a
worthiness enchantment magic was somehow
involved and then he was able to do all
kinds of stuff with it he could teleport
he could fly you could do all manner of
things it wasn't until recent years when
jason aaron came back and gave us the
untold origin of thor's hammer when he
basically established that the hammer of
thor is basically possessed by this sort
of cosmic storm that was equal in power
to odin himself odin was able to
basically channel the storm into a chunk
of uru send it over to the dwarves have
them craft it into a hammer and then his
son was eventually able to pick it up in
this particular story what seems to be
going on or at least what jason aaron is
hitting at is that much like the hammer
of thor being sentient this ultimate
hammer is sentient as well but it's
basically sentient with the wrath of a
universe that's long since been
destroyed all that energy and all that
power is channeled directly into the
hammer itself and so what it means is
that it's quite literally dominating
volstag and that's why it's such a huge
deal is because in the midst of all this
one thing to keep in mind is that it
also reminds us that jane foster is
still dying
one of the things that jason aaron
established almost immediately before
jane foster ever picked up the hammer in
the first place is that it was ever
going to be a temporary thing that
because of the fact that she has cancer
because she is basically dying she does
undergo chemotherapy but every time she
becomes thor it purges the chemotherapy
from her system and so in a sense she
might as well have never had
chemotherapy at all and so the result is
that she's constantly dying of cancer
and what it'll do is it'll eventually
get to the point where she will die
altogether and she will never have the
hammer again she'll be dead but what
this does is this actually transfers us
for a second to a place called
muspelheim the realm of surter the realm
of these fire demons and we actually end
up picking up with his daughter cinder
now the crazy thing about this is that
sir has been dead for quite some time
certain was basically destroyed by odin
or at least his essence was destroyed by
odin and so what this did is it allowed
for some measure of a power vacuum
within muscleheim itself now this vacuum
was filled almost immediately by cinder
but this is the first time we see her
character this is the first time she's
being introduced certain had had a whole
bunch of children over the years she was
the first one to basically prove herself
worthy of taking over her father's role
remember sirder is this guy who
basically has it out for odin and all
the asgardians and a lot of that's
because of the fact that odin and his
brothers had faced off against certain
odin was responsible for imprisoning
certain in earth and so it's really one
of those things where it's more like a
blood vendetta as opposed to you know
some eternal battle that was always
destined to happen or something along
those lines but the idea is that with
malekith showing up alongside loki keep
in mind originally loki was sent to
malakith by freya to be a spy for the
asgardians somewhere along the line he
seems to have turn-coded and abandoned
his mother's cause taking up his cause
with malakith but we don't know that for
certain loki is very much a wild card in
this story he seems to be an ally but we
don't know for sure but regardless of
the reasoning behind it malekith running
this sort of council of realms the idea
is to basically make sure that everybody
has their own role to play and to make
sure they're playing their roles
effectively the fire demons are some of
the most formidable beings out there
when they show up and they start
cleansing places those places are gone
but for malikith is also a very tenuous
situation because if they chose to turn
on him then not only would he be facing
the asgardians he would be facing the
fire demons and so again the goal is to
very much make sure that they're playing
their role but what he also does is
essentially show up and say you have a
new thor on the scene and this new thor
needs to be taken care of as quickly as
possible because this new thor was able
to single-handedly take down your entire
army now what this does is it leads to a
battle between war thor and cinder and
this is something i want to talk about
for a second because this is interesting
to me if this were certain this battle
would be over before it even started
when it comes to someone like certain
you're talking about a guy who went
toe-to-toe with odin killed odin prior
to the events of ragnarok we're talking
about a very capable being that's out
there certain being out of the picture
his daughter center taking the place
she's not on that same level of power
she's capable but she's not on that
level and so what this does is it gives
us a battle between the two but i don't
want you to see this as something you
know with regards to warfare being a lot
more powerful than he is not at all this
is not like war thor fighting certain
the other half of this is that the death
of all these kids keep playing over
constantly in the mind of volstak and
that's what drives him while the hammer
does kind of seize control of him the
idea of feeding these images into his
mind time and time again of these kids
dying continues to push him to the point
where all he wants to do is destroy all
he wants to do is see the death of all
things now because of the fact that that
war the work hears nothing about
everything that exists in muspelheim
what it does is it brings him and it
brings jane foster thor directly into
conflict with one another now the reason
why this happens is because of the fact
that in the mind of jane foster while
cinder is a terrible ruler while cinder
is a terrible being you know all she
wants to do is just sort of see the
destruction of the asgardians the cinder
herself is not a reflection of the
beings within mass behind there are
innocents there there are young children
who are fire demon children but they are
young children nonetheless they have not
had the chance to actually grow and
adopt their own mindset jane foster sees
these kids as basically innocents the
ability to move on and to have their own
lives if you know muspelheim is going to
be freed of the control of cinder and
the entire legacy of certain that it
starts with the defeat of cinder herself
and then giving the survivors the
opportunity to forge their own path but
in the eyes of jane foster it is not
acceptable to kill kids and so what this
does is it basically brings jane foster
and war thor to this place this this
sort of in-between area called the
yawning void now what this does is it
basically seems to indicate this empty
space in between dimensions or maybe
where all life seemed to hail from or
something along those lines the
asgardian depiction of the origin of all
things is a little bit different from
what we're normally used to in the main
marvel universe in the beginning there
was only just darkness that was it and
then darkness somehow gave form to life
life gave form to more life gave form to
planets gave form to you know stars
systems different things like that but
it all started with absolute darkness
and the idea is that the yawning void is
that absolute darkness it's that lack of
anything there's nothing there they're
basically fighting in a space where
there is no concern about you know
anybody being in danger there's no
concern about loss of life or anything
along those lines but the idea is that
the fight between the two of them just
starts spreading through i mean it
literally tears through all these
different facets of the realms in the
sense that those who were in the
equivalent of hell within the asgardian
mythos can see this fight take place you
know those who are in heaven where
angela comes from you can see this fight
taking place it's really not until jane
foster takes the ultimate hammer of thor
that we as the reader learn that it has
been possessing volstagg the entire time
poisoning his mind but again it's sort
of a wild scenario because once odin's
son realizes that volstagg is war thor
that volstag is going on this path of
tearing things up initially odin son
tries to reason with him the problem
with this is that volstag seems to be
beyond the point of reason i mean he's
literally a mad dog driven by the only
motivation to just see all things
destroyed it's just nothing but anger
and wrath and rage and so it's kind of
cool because it's almost one of those
things of music sues the savage beast in
the sense that jane foster simply puts
the hammer down and lets all pretense go
and approaches volstag as just a normal
person now this is cool because this is
designed to show jane foster as being
effective as not just thor but also as
jane foster the character in this
instance odin's son basically just kind
of sends the hammer away tells the
hammer get out of here he's not supposed
to be here you know sends it back to
asgard and that's really about it but
it's this idea that malikith continues
his campaign of grabbing all these
different armies from around the
asgardian realm and bringing them to his
cause his next stop is the realm of
heaven his next stop is to basically
step in to the angels themselves and say
become part of my council of realms help
me basically conquer everything and i
will restore your rightful place among
the asgardian landscape
okay so we are getting into the death of
the mighty thor and this is an amazing
story i mean this is the end of jane
foster right like we've talked about
this before anybody who read jason
aaron's thor god of thunder knew that
jane foster was gonna go away she was
never gonna stay thor permanently we saw
that at the end of the story like we saw
that at the end of thor god of thunder
that like odin's son gets the hammer
back eventually and jane foster was only
ever a temporary thing why people
freaked out about her becoming thor i'm
not really sure i assume it's because
they didn't read that story so they
didn't know which is fine but
nonetheless this basically deals with
the return of a villain called mangog
now i want to talk about man gog for a
second because this guy is a beast he is
an absolute host but it's kind of funny
because he was initially designed to be
a one-off in marvel comics uh he
originally appeared in thor issues 154
through 157 by stan lee and jack kirby
and the whole idea of introducing man
gog was to basically say like over the
course of asgard's history odin had done
some pretty cd things now for the most
part odin had been depicted as a guy who
had like a nefarious past we didn't know
a whole lot about it but it was one of
those guys where he just kind of did
whatever he felt needed to be done but
in this three-part story it was
basically revealed to us that somewhere
along the line odin had essentially like
destroyed a race of beings and that this
race of beings had kind of poured their
hatred and their animosity into a
singular being and that arose in the
form of man gog now this was very very
like cloak and dagger there wasn't a
whole lot of explanation offered there
and so over the course of that story by
the time issue number 157 came around
what ended up happening is the beings
that were destroyed by uh by odin have
been returned to the physical form and
because of that their animosity and
hatred had no reason to exist and so the
result was that man gog basically went
away now in thor issues god issue 195
i think i want to say it was in 1972 it
was written by jerry conway and what
jerry conway did was actually bring man
gog back and that's one of the big
issues is because technically there was
no reason for him to be alive when it
comes to the character of man gog
usually this means that like everybody's
gonna get wrecked now the only real
exception to this came in walt
simonson's run uh of the mighty thor i
guess of thor when you ended up having
man gog who is basically beaten by thor
and technically that shouldn't have
really happened either it should have
been a standstill or man god should have
won the problem with this is that man
gog's desire is to destroy asgard and so
if he had won then asgard would have
been obliterated so it was one of those
things where like man god kind of had to
lose but the whole walt simonson run of
thor was really designed for the purpose
of like taking what jack kirby
originally did and tales of asgard
rolling that into the main thor stories
and then just kind of rebuilding the
entirety of the asgardian mythos
especially because of the fact that thor
had been struggling for a few years
between the time that jack kirby and
stan lee stopped writing him and the
time that walt simonson picked it up so
the fact remains here what this does is
this initially picks up with man gog
facing off against war thor now again we
did that whole story arc with war thor
basically uh this is volkstag wheeling
the hammer of ultimate thor and really
what happens here is like man god rolls
right through him man gog just keeps
coming and coming one step after another
and no matter what war thor does he
can't win there's no conceivable way he
can defeat this guy and so what ends up
happening is you end up having man god
who basically seizes the hammer of war
thor and then just crushes it with his
bare hands that's the power of man gog
is this just all this hatred and all
this vitriol coalesced into a singular
being given physical form and so it's
absolutely insane in terms of all the
power that he possesses
the following this battle we pick up
with jane foster who's just kind of arm
wrestling hercules you know and it's
kind of funny because hercules is like
hey like you know whenever you're not
fighting against villains or something
like that like if you want to get
together you know and like knock some
boots you know i'm down
[Laughter]
which is amazing but it's basically
odin's son showing up to jane foster and
saying you need to come with me because
war thor's been absolutely wrecked and
uh something's amiss here like there is
a being out there who just totally
decimated what thor and we have to find
out who this is now of course what ended
up happening too is volkswagen himself
had just kind of basically said like man
gog is coming and this is when like
odin's son basically reveals to jane
foster like man gog is on his way and if
man gog is on his way we're all
basically doomed because it took
everything i had to go toe-to-toe with
him and i don't know if you can handle
this which is true like no one knows if
jane foster would be able to hold her
own against someone like mango but in
this scenario like he basically says
look like you can do what you can hold
off as best you can at the end of the
day this may be a battle that you will
lose that you will not survive and so
what ends up happening is she travels to
asgard to basically besiege odin now
remember in terms of like the whole war
of realms which is still going on that's
been the whole ongoing idea of like
jason aaron's run on thor everything
else has been a secondary plot for the
most part the nine realms are in chaos
they're in turmoil this whole war is
going on and like odin is almost nowhere
to be found he's just sitting inside his
throne room standing next to freya and
that's really about it and so jane
foster showing up this is what's so cool
jane foster shows up as just herself
cancer-ridden jane foster no more
capable of defeating odin than just any
normal human being out there but she
basically shows up and says like either
you can sit in there and be a coward or
you can come out here and you can issue
the order to recall all the asgardians
from across the nine realms and tell
them like they have to return here
because we have to face man gog we have
to face them together and it's not
really one of those things like if we
all hold hands we'll win it's one of
those things like if we're not all here
we're all going to die the other thing
here is that cole boerson the brother of
thor is basically like like a steward
more or less of the throne of asgard
while odin is kind of out there and
really cole borson is completely
ill-equipped to be the one to run the
show he's not incompetent right like
he's not a goof the issue with this is
that he doesn't really have the wisdom
of odin so there are times when like he
should stand down and he doesn't in this
instance he should recall all the forces
of asgard but he's not he's kind of
staying strong and saying look we'll do
our own thing you know we've got this
sorted out odin basically makes his
appearance he shows up and says look i
will not stand for anyone calling me a
coward like i will not stand for anyone
being out here telling me that i've
somehow failed that i'm somehow derelict
in my duties like i am odin i run asgard
i was running asgard before you were
born i will run asgard after you are
dead i have seen more than you could
possibly imagine i faced off against
celestials i've done all kinds of
different things i've went toe-to-toe
against galactus you are just a chick
who showed up on the moon one day got
lucky and picked up the hammer get out
of here that's odin's entire response to
this whole thing and it's so cool
because i'd be curious to ask jason
aaron why he didn't take things in this
direction odin could just obliterate
jane foster especially in her current
form i would wager the reason he doesn't
do that is because of the fact that thor
was with jane foster for quite some time
and even though they're not together
anymore there's still a lot of
connection between the two of them even
if they're only the closest to friends
and so to kill jane foster would be to
alienate his son potentially start a
civil war in asgard proper and odin
would be forced to either choose a side
let the war commence asgard would just
kind of be obliterated so there would be
consequences to that particular act but
what we end up having is freyja who
basically comes to simply steps out and
says like jane foster's right we have to
do something if we do not martial our
forces we're all going to die and so
what we do is we switch to heimdall who
of course is at the rainbow bridge
watching like he always does and then in
comes mangogog having made his way to
asgard onto the rainbow bridge and like
literally begins this onslaught and
that's something that i want you guys to
notice here this is not like an even
battle right it's not like heimdall's
holding his own and he's holding off and
doing the best he can i mean this is
like he's he's wrecked like that there's
no conflict here he's bitten in half the
rainbow bridge is totally destroyed
that's the power of man god the other
half of this is jane foster's
chemotherapy that's how jason aaron put
a clock on jane fosh that's basically
how he said like she's gonna die the
jane foster has cancer she has breast
cancer every time she changes into thor
it washes away the chemotherapy and so
basically she starts back at square one
and so what this essentially means is
that it's the equivalent of her having
never undergone chemotherapy in the
first place it shortens her lifespan and
so you have like doctor strange you have
various people who were here trying to
cure her in truth this is really just
like a stopgap or a hope is really all
it is when captain marvel the original
captain marvel died in 1984 in the death
of his character by jim starlin he died
of cancer so it is a foregone conclusion
in marvel comics that when a character
gets cancer they die there's no
conceivable way to get past that with
jane foster having undergone you know
chemotherapy multiple times what ends up
happening here is that she's essentially
told if you turn into thor again you
will die like this is your last shot let
the chemotherapy happen let it run its
course because you're essentially this
this whole scenario basically plays out
like this is the first time you're
basically undergoing chemotherapy and so
what ends up happening is a hammer
basically appears and it's just got like
it speaks to her it says look like man
gog is there you have to fight you have
to show up and that's the indication now
the other half of this is we switch to
freya who basically takes control of the
destroyer armor now again this is one of
those huge moments the destroyer armor
is kind of like this huge creation that
was that was really performed by odin it
was originally designed to stop the
third host of the of the celestials i
can never remember if it was the third
or the fourth but regardless of the
circumstances the destroyer armor was
created to combat the celestials but
because of the fact that like man gog
showing up here and just taking the full
brunt of the power of the destroyer
armor there's nothing that can be done
it's one of these things where it's like
thor has to respond that's the power of
mjolnir the power of the hammer this is
something that i also want you guys to
notice odin is terrified and we never
see that but it's always been that way
it's always been the idea that like the
man gog is the one thing that scares
odin more than anybody else because one
it's like all his past sins come to
haunt him and two like there's no real
conceivable way or at least there
shouldn't be any conceivable way to stop
mangak and so odin being terrified for
his life man god taunting him the entire
time i've destroyed your destroyer armor
i've destroyed your rainbow bridge i've
destroyed everybody who's coming for me
i'm coming for you pops like i'm coming
for you old man and his curtains the sun
is setting on the asgardian empire
that's just the way it is but the other
thing to keep in mind here is like with
thor and odin's son traveling back to
asgard this is cool because it's him and
his father facing off against like mango
but the reality of the situation is they
don't really expect to win instead this
is kind of like the whole scenario with
like hyperion and odin son facing off
against the beyonders at the conclusion
of hickman's avengers and new avengers
right like they knew they were going to
lose it was one of those things of like
if we're going to go out we're not going
to go out sitting in chairs we're not
going to go out and just let man god
destroy us we're going to go out in a
blaze of glory like if our legends
survive then like people will speak of
the day that thor and odin's son fought
to their last breath against the man gog
and just like fought with honor and died
of the bittering i mean that's that's
that's i'm sorry uh you know fought and
died and and like you know fought with
thought of the bitter end like that's
gonna be the whole story like that
that's what they're shooting for because
remember asgard itself is very much like
rooted in the honor of combat and so
really like they don't expect to win
there's no real way for them to win here
and so what you end up having is jane
foster seizing control of the hammer
turning back into thor and then racing
off to asgard and this again this
basically means like jane foster's going
to die and so what you end up having is
her showing up and like holding her own
as best she can and facing off against
the man goku and she's able to she's
able to do pretty well just because the
nature of the hammer because the hammer
is so powerful but in reality again like
this guy is supposed to be unstoppable
and jason aaron stays true for the most
part to the nature of mango despite all
the power that jane foster has with this
hammer at the end of the day it doesn't
really matter because what she does is
she basically like goes to hurl man gog
into the sun like the whole idea is just
throw him into the sun call it a day let
him just like burn alive you know in
this insane amount of heat but man gog
manages to kind of ricochet his way
around and then basically come back and
when he does like he just starts
wrecking jane foster again like he just
starts tearing her apart alongside like
odin's son and alongside like odin
himself it really does seem to be the
end and so what happens is jane foster
basically wraps the man gog in chains
and then like throw the hammer into the
sun with man gog in tow and so instead
of him just kind of ricocheting around
like he did before he actually flies
into the sun directly but like everyone
like like odin and odin's son and freya
everyone's screaming at jane foster not
to do this because if they do it'll
destroy the hammer but at the end of the
day like she doesn't care the only thing
that matters to jane foster is
destroying man gog like preserving
what's left of asgard and so when the
hammer flies into the sun man god flies
into the sun and both are seemingly
destroyed at this moment at this point
right now there is no more no more
mjolnir the hammer of thor is gone the
man god's destroyed and everything and
asgard is safe but jane foster
ultimately succumbs to her cancer she
essentially just dies i mean there's
there's nothing left for her there so
with that being said guys uh if you are
new here to comments explained make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah like i'm really curious because the
aftermath issue comes out in about a
month or probably about three weeks now
maybe two weeks because i think the
story is about two weeks out uh but like
yeah so so we'll get like the aftermath
i'm curious to see i mean the hammer
will come back people are probably going
to freak out just be like no your
millionaire can't be destroyed like yeah
you're right it can't be destroyed it
will come back
i mean i don't imagine why he wouldn't
like it it's definitely gonna make his
return how it makes this return i don't
know because there's no more ultimate
thor hammer that hammer was crushed by
mango like beta ray bill still has storm
breaker but he's floating out there
somewhere i'm willing to surmise
whatever weapon thor gets in the comics
will be the weapon he gets in in
infinity war mar was just gonna roll it
over
that's exactly what's gonna happen but
anyway guys uh yeah if you're new here
to comics explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and i will catch
you all later peace